[Music]
station to control visual confirmation
of master over children I see it it's
gonna heat you know is that your CDs
c'mere c'mere c'mere c'mere c'mere
c'mere here tell the committee they
simple safe and sound each passing year
has seen on estimate of the probability
of life in space increase more and more
scientists feel that contact is no
longer something beyond our dreams but
is a natural event in the history of
mankind that will perhaps occur within
the lifetime of many of us there affinor
Rovers on Mars for 20 years I wonder
what this one's found the sample is a
large single-cell unmistakeably
biological the first incontrovertible
proof of life beyond Earth you're
finally a daddy it's gonna be a big
custody battle over this one
was beautiful the manner of which we
first meet life beyond death may
determine the character of all our
subsequent relations let us never forget
the fatal impact we've had upon
innumerable people's on this earth
people who trusted us befriended us and
who we destroyed by our thoughtlessness
the light we know the specifications on
them we don't know what it is
this etiquettes gave to us the risk all
human life we're out of order you don't
know what it can do the light we know
the life we know
perhaps that is where we ought to begin
with ourselves
the missions primary goal has been
acheived looking at